let's say that we know some I have some
object and when it's outside of water
its weight is so wait outside of water
is I don't know 10 Newtons and let's say
well then I submerge it in water I put
on a weighing machine in water it's
weight so let's call it weight in water
is I don't know it's two Newtons so what
must be going on here well the water
must be exerting some type of upward
force to counteract at least eight
Newtons of the person's original of not
the person the objects originally this
would be a very small person
most people's weights in Newtons are are
in the hundreds but anyway so so and and
that difference is the buoyant force
right so a way to think about it is once
you put the object in the water so let's
say it's a you know it could be a cube
but now to be a cube could be anything
it's in the water so let me draw the
water this is the water up here we know
that we have a downward there's a
downward weight right that is 10 Newtons
but we know that once it's in the water
the net weight is 2 Newtons so there
must be some force acting upwards on the
object of eight Newtons right and that's
the buoyant force that we learned about
in the previous video and the video
about Archimedes principle this is the
buoyant force so the full the buoyant
force is equal to 10 minus 2 is equal to
8 right that's that's how much the water
is pushing up and what is that also
equal to that equals the volume about
the weight of the water displaced so 8
Newtons
is equal to weight of water displaced
and what is the weight of the water
displaced that's the volume of the water
displaced times the density of water
times gravity right and so what is the
volume of water displaced well it's just
the volume of water divided 8 Newtons by
the density of water is
1,000 kilograms per meter cubed this is
8 Newton so a Newton is what kilogram
kilogram meter per second squared and
then what's gravity it's 9 point 8 meter
per second squared and if we look at all
the units they actually do turn out with
just you end up having just meters cubed
but let's do the math so we get let me
get my calculator so I have 8 divided by
1000 divided by 9 point 8 is equal to 8
point two times 10 to the negative four
equals eight point two times 10 to the
minus 4 meters cubic meters so just
knowing the difference in the weight of
an object I can figure out the value the
difference when I put it in water I can
figure out the volume and so this could
be a fun game to do next time your
friends come over is way yourself
outside of water then get a some type of
spring or water proof waterproof
weighing machine put it at the bottom of
your pool stand on it and figure out
what your weight is assuming that your
your your dense enough to go all the way
into the water but you could figure out
somehow your weight in water and then
you would know your volume there's other
ways you could just figure out how much
the the surface of the water increases
and take that water away but anyway this
was interesting just knowing how much
the buoyant force of the water was or
how much lighter we are when we go the
object goes into the water we can figure
out the volume of the object and this
might seem like a very small volume but
just keep in mind in a meter cubed in a
meter cubed you have let's see you have
27 square feet right you have 27 square
feet so if we multiply that number times
27 it equals 0.02 0.02
square feet roughly and point O to
square feet how many in a square foot
there's actually c12 to the third power
times 12 times 12 is equal to 17 28
times point no 2 so this is actually 34
square inches so the object isn't as as
small as you may have thought it to be
it's actually you know it's like maybe a
little bit bigger than 3 inches by 3
inches by 3 inches so it's a reasonably
sized object anyway let's do another
problem let's say I have some I have
some balsa wood and I know that the
density of balsa wood is 130 kilograms
per meter cubed meter cubed that's the
density of balsa wood and I have some
you know big cube of balsa wood and what
I want to know is if I put that so let
me draw the water that's the water and I
have some big cube of balsa wood which
I'll i'm doing brown so that big cube of
balsa wood and the water should go on
top of it just so you see that it's
submerged in the water alright I want to
know what percentage of the cube goes
below the surface of the water
interesting question so how do we do
that well for for the object to be at
rest for this big cube to be addressed
there must be zero net forces on this
object right so in that situation the
buoyant force must completely equal the
weight or you know the force of gravity
well what's the force of gravity going
to be well the force of gravity is just
the weight of the object and that's the
volume of let's just say the wood volume
of the balsa wood times the density of
the balsa wood times the density of
balsa wood times gravity and what's the
buoyant force the buoyant force is equal
to the volume of the displaced water
right volume of displaced water but
that's also well it's the volume of
displaced water and it's the volume of
the of the cube that's been submerged
the part of the cube that's submerged
that's volume that's also equal to the
amount of volume of water displaced
right so you could say that's the volume
of the block submerged which is the same
thing remember as the volume of the
water displaced times the density of
water times gravity remember this is
density of water so remember the buoyant
force is just equal to the weight of the
water displaced and that's just the
volume of the water displaced times the
density 400 times gravity and of course
the volume of the water displaced is the
exact same thing as the volume of the
block that's actually submerged and
since the block is stationary it's not
accelerating upwards or downwards we
know that these two quantities must
equal each other so the volume of the
wood the entire volume not just the
amount this submerged times the density
of the wood times gravity must equal the
volume of the wood submerged which is
equal to the volume of the water
displaced times the density of water
times gravity oh we have the
acceleration of gravity we have that on
both sides so we can cross it out let me
switch colors to ease the monotony and
then let's see what happens if we if we
divide both sides by the volume of the
balsa wood you get let's put this over
the year so you get well let's divide
both swell I'm just rearranging this
equation I think you'll figure it out we
can get put divide both sides by that
you get the volume submerged
divided by the volume of the balsa wood
right I just divided both sides by VB
and divide and switch sides is equal to
analyst is equal to the density of the
balsa wood divided by the density of
water that makes sense I just I just did
a couple of quick algebraic operations
but hopefully that you know get rid of
the
and that should make sense to you and
now we're ready to solve our problem
because my original question is what
percentage of of the object is submerged
and so that's exactly this number right
if we say what this is the volume
submerged over the total volume this is
the percent submerged and so that equals
the density of balsa wood which is 130
kilograms per meter cubed divided by the
density of water which is 1,000
kilograms per meter cubed so 130 divided
by 1000 is point 1 3 so V s over VB is
equal to 0.1 3 which is the same thing
as 13% so exactly 13% of this object
will be of this balsa wood block will be
submerged into the water that's that's
pretty neat to me and it actually didn't
have to be a block it could have been
shaped like a horse I'll see in the next
video